hello everyone
my name is shin and in this video i'm
going to demonstrate how to deploy a
hipaa align foundation gcp
infrastructure using terraform
and i'm going to use the telephone
engine and the cicd pipelines from the
data protection toolkit
to facilitate and simplify the whole
process
what is terraform engine terraform
engine is a framework to jump start
your organization onto gcp it is an open
source terraform module generator that
puts together telephone resources
into complete deployments with values
that are specific to your infrastructure
terraform engine offers different types
of recipes and here i'm demonstrating
the foundation recipe
which is the most common baseline piece
that healthcare-focused gcp
infrastructure should usually set up
so what is a foundation recipe
foundation recipe helps you set up a
structure like this
it will help you set up a devops project
used for remote
telephone state management ci cd
resources
to test and deploy your telephone
configs automatically
it will also set up a audi project which
is which is used to
host two audio lock syncs a short term
one year bigquery locksync
and also a long-term seven-year cloud
storage lock sync
and in addition the foundation
foundation recipe
also set up a monitoring project which
is used to host the full setting
infrastructure
and for seti is used to scan and monitor
your gcp organization for potential
security policy violations
so this is actually a terrifying engine
config and i will use this
to generate the telephone config using
terraform engine
and so here you can see i'm
specifying the recipe to be the
foundation recipe from the default
templates offered by terreform engine
and in each of the data block i can
specify details for each component
so for example for devops project i
specify the project id to be dpt
demo dash 1-devops and similarly for
audit i can specify the name
or the project id for the for the
project itself i can also specify
the data set name and also a bucket name
for the for the audio log syncs
and note that we also deliver a set of
default organization policies
which is based on best practices and
it's a good set of organizing policies
that you can use to to start with in
your organization
and also here we have the cicd block
this block will configure the ci cd
components
which will set for example which github
repo to monitor
which branch to monitor to detect
changes
push to that branch and auto deploy the
changes in that branch to your gcp
infrastructure and it also allows
set additional for example project
owners to a specific group
and things like those
and also note that there is a disabled
block
and there is one attribute set to true
which is the bootstrap gcs backend so
the meaning is in the telephone config
it generates that are used to create
the create the devops project and the
central remote state bucket
configure that specific deployments to
save the state locally not remotely
the reason is because that deployment
specifically
is creating that devops project and
remote state bucket
used to store the remote state so if we
haven't
create those resources how can we store
the state remotely
so we have to do this in a two-phase way
first we set this to true
meaning disable the remote back-end
so the state will be saved locally and
then i'm going to flip this to
false i'm going to regenerate the
terraform configs
with the changed config here and that
will give me
the new config and that config will have
the
the state configured to remote then i
can run carefully need
to backup the state to the remote state
bucket
so a quick overview for uh what i'm
going to do in this demo
so i'm going to use terraform engine and
this config
to generate the telephone configs and
save them to a local git repository
and they will later be checked in to my
private github repository which will be
the
source of truth for the telephone
configs for
my testing or demo infrastructure
then i will manually deploy the devops
project and the ci cd resources
so later deployments or modifications to
your infrastructure can be made through
pull requests
and auto deployed by post-submit copio
jobs once
the pr is approved tested and merged
then i will make a commit to include all
the configs
send it as a pr for review let
pre-submit test to run
and pass i will merge the pr and let
post submit cloud bill job to kick in
and auto deploy
the rest of the resources that were not
deployed manually
those will include the audit project
audit resources
monitoring project and facade resources
and a few things to note terraform
engine does not
create the organization we need to
create an empty
organization first and configure the
billing account properly as well
and the person who is going to do the
initial deployments of the devops
project
and the city resources should have the
necessary permission to create project
use the billing account set in
permissions at organization level
and other ones if necessary
okay so if we actually go to a terminal
and i'm going to run the term from
engine uh binary or command
so tefl engine is uh shipped as a
gold binary and so first let me show you
this directory which will be the target
uh directory that i will use to save the
uh generated telephone config and it is
a
local git repository and it is
configured to
all connect it to my private github
repository here
and this repository is specifically
this one right now it's empty i'm going
to push
i'm going to like send prs to including
my configs
to this to this remote repository
so here if um to run the terraform
engine command
i run something like this so i specify
the config path
pointing to the demo.yaml which is this
file i just showed you
and then i specified the output path to
be the repost
demo which is this directory here and
now it's empty
so now i run this command it's pretty
straightforward
um so now i come back here it's this
structure is no longer empty
as you can see three directories are
generated are generated
and if we open this
directory and see what has been created
so let's see the bootstrap directory
first
so if we look at the man.tf we can see
that
this terraform config is actually
creating the devops project
using the project factory module and
it's also creating
the a storage bucket
and this bucket will be the terraform
remote state bucket
and it's also configuring additional iem
settings
so this will go first i'm going to
deploy this manually first
and remember i'm going to go back to the
traffic engine config
flip this to false and regenerate the
term config
so that will make a change in this part
actually
and i'm going to do the terrible we need
to back up the state
from this deployment to the remote state
bucket as well
after the state bucket has been created
and after the bootstrap directory
is completed i'm going to move forward
and move on to the cicd directory and
this directory
configures the cicd pipelines and this
one has to be done manually
um before um before the ci cd pipeline
is actually created
so this one actually configures a bunch
of apis and also im permissions to
to enable the cloud your service account
to view
and make modifications to your gcp
infrastructure
and most importantly it configures three
cloud build triggers
two presumably trigger to watch for prs
pull requests
and one post submit trigger to watch for
pushes to
to a specific branch and in this case
i've configured that branch to be master
branch
and this config directory contains the
actual cloud build config
that will be executed in the cloud build
job
so once that is completed i'm going to
send a pr to include all the configs in
in all three folders bootstrap cic and
org and remember that the org folder
was not deployed manually so that will
be handled
by the ci cd pipeline so let's take a
look look at this org folder
so the org folder contains all the other
resources that does not need to be done
manually and all the resources that will
be handled by the cicd pipelines
and in this case as part of the
foundation recipe it will um
create the audio project create audio
resources
create a monitoring project and create
the monitoring resources which is the
four set
infrastructure and oh as well as the
organization policy as well
and so if we actually open each of the
directory and take a look so this
project dot dpt dash demo dash one dash
audit
slash project in the configs in this
directory
correspond to the config that creates
the audit project but not the other
resources
the other resources was actually are
contained in this main.tf under the
audit folder
as you can see here we are enabling all
possible audit logs
for all different all three types and
all supported services
and we are creating two audi log sync
the bigquery one
and also the cloud storage one and as
you can see for example the cloud
storage one is set to
expire in seven years so that's the
audit
and let's take a look at the monitoring
component as well
so similarly this uh monitor
slash project this man.tf uh contains
the terraform config to create the
monitoring project itself
and then if we go to this monitor folder
open the main.tf
as you can see here we are creating the
network
for for seti we're creating a another
router and a net to enable facility to
communicate
because if for seti will we always set
it as a private instance
so we need that net to enable facility
to communicate to the internet to
download certain packages during
startup and then we use this facility
module to
uh to stand up the entire foster
infrastructure and this is actually
pretty complicated
because fossetti has few few components
including
avm fuse cloud storage buckets
a bunch of firewall rules and also a
cloud sql database
so this will be handled by the cic
pipeline
and lastly we are let's take a look at
this organization policy folder
so this is the organization policy uh
delivered by the traffic engine
templates by default
we did not configure them with any
attribute
and these are the default ones i know
that for example if you specify
a allowed shared vpc host project to
owning specific projects
those information will be propagated to
this
to this part and then once these
policies are enforced
only those projects can be used as
shared vpc host projects
okay so that's a quick overview of the
configs that are generated by the target
engine based on the travel engine config
here so now let's do the actual
deployment
so first so this is the the directory
containing the
turbine config so let's do the bootstrap
deployment first so to do terraform
deployment refers to timeframe needs
which will pull down the module
resources and other careful provider
resources
and this is now complete then i do
terrify apply
so usually you can also do a telephone
plan to show the plan
of the resources it's going to create or
modify
and in this case because tearful apply
also shows you the
plan so it's okay so i i should take a
look at this
this plan and making sure it's it's
doing the right thing and it looks good
to me so i press yes to let it continue
so this deployment will create the
devops project
and also the central remote terraform
state bucket
as you can see that it's creating the
project and all of them
are handled by turbo
i do know that the state the turf and
state for this
deployment specifically is stored
locally
and we are going to modify the travel
engine config to change that
uh disabled uh attribute to false and
regenerate the terraform config
and the new one will have the state
configured to be remote
then we determine need to up the state
uh
so it's almost finished
it's creating a bucket like the bucket
has been created
and it's completed so now i'm going back
to this config
change this to false meaning
save the state remotely then i
rerun the transform engine command to
regenerate the terraform configs
and here let's take a look at what it
has changed
so the thing it changed is actually
this part it adds additional as an
additional block
to configure the back end to be gcs and
using the bucket
that are just created
so i'm going to do a telephone we need
to transfer the state from local to
remote
so it detects that the backend of the
state has changed
and it asked me if i want to transfer
the state from local to remote and i
answer yes
so this part is done so that means the
the bootstrap deployment is completed
so after this i'm moving on to the cicd
folder
or cicd deployment and one thing that i
need to do first
is i need to manually connect
the github repo to the cloud build
triggers
in the ui in the cloud console uh the
reason is because i need to grant cloud
build
a permission to access my private github
repo
and that part currently that is not
supported by any automation
so this actually this dpt demo dash one
dash devops project was just actually
uh created by the previous deployment
and here i'm connecting
the repository and i'm selecting the
github
github repo
and i choose the right github account
and i choose
choose write a repository and and
connect repository
it will ask if i want to create a
default push trigger
i skip for now because i'm going to
create uh my own triggers
so this part is completed so actually
since where we are on this cloud console
let's take a look at the state bucket we
just created
so this is the bucket that was created
by the previous deployment
and it's here already
so now if we go back to this directory
and we go to the cicd folder
and we do a deployment and similarly
terraform we need
and then tearful apply
and i take a look at the plan
of the resources it's going to create or
modify for me
they all looks fine and i press i
type yes to continue
so after this deployment is finished i
expect to see
three carburetor triggers being added in
this page
and they are not here yet
so these are completed
and if we go here and i refresh
and i see three triggers are created and
if we open one of them
we can see it's configured to watch for
my
repo at the master branch which is what
we have configured
in the transform engine config here
okay so at this point i've configured or
i have deployed
the bootstrap uh part and also the ci cd
part and so the the
the rest of the configs in the org
folder will now be handled by the ci cd
pipeline
and actually at this moment i can remove
myself as
the owner or organization at me or being
a kind of user
from the organization since i've done
all the manual steps that i need to do
and the rest should be handled and it
can be handled by the cicd pipelines
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make a commit
uh to include all the three folders
and i will i'm going to send send a pr a
pull request
trying to merge these configs into the
master branch
of that private github repository
so let's make sure that i'm on the depth
branch because i'm pushing to the depth
branch and making a pr
from that branch to the master branch
and i include all the configs that are
created by the terreform engine
and then make a commit let's say
auto generated by
tire from engine
and save and exit and
and then we push this commit
to the remote dev branch
and it will come to this
part and then let's create a pull
request
and it as you can see it has all the
configs from the three directories
then we create a pull request
so as you can see two pre-submit job has
started running
and those are the two presumably
triggers we have configured to watch for
prs sending or trying to merge
changes to the master branch and
so it because i'm using a personal repo
and uh
i think i didn't uh so i cannot
configure branch protection rules to
to for example block the submission of
this pr
if some pre-submit test has failed but
in a
enterprise or organization repository
such as google cloud platform
you can and you should configure the
pre-submit test to block submission
of your pr and also i should ask for a
review from one of my teammates
or and but for the demoing purposes i'm
just skipping that part for now but in
the actual develop
development cycle for prod or for dev or
other involvement
you should um ask for a review from your
teammate
and also making sure the pre-summer
tests pass
so let's take a look at what are wrong
in those two free submit tests
so let's take a look take a look at this
one first
so this one is doing a telephone
formatting check
terror ground formatting check to making
sure the
code is the code health is is good and
we are also doing a terrible validate to
making sure that there's no
simple syntax errors in your terraform
conflicts
and and let's take a look at the other
one
that one is still running and this one
is actually printing out
a speculative plan similar to what we
just
did um uh in the local machine to
when you do a travel apply or telephone
plan it demonstrates or shows you
the potential changes that will be made
to your infrastructure once
the um the change is applied so this is
the similar idea
where we are running a telephone plan
to show you the changes that will be
made to your infrastructure
and in this case we are deploying or we
are
creating the resources for the audit
project
and the monitoring project we are also
configuring the organization policies
uh which are all the configs
in the org folder that was not deployed
manually
by me and they are now handled by the
cicd pipelines
and for example as you can see here on
this deployment
and this one specifically is creating
the audit project
and this one specifically is configuring
the audio logs for
for all three different types and also
for all supported services
and these are configuring or adding the
the two lock syncs
and the rest are mostly for facadi
because i think fossetti has
about 50 to 60 resources to be created
so in a development cycle you should
take a look
in detail of what is going to be changed
in your infrastructure especially when
there are
deletions so for example we add an extra
step
at the end to detect potential deletions
of resources
um that will result if
you uh checking your merge your changes
and in this case because you're well
creating everything from scratch
and no resource deletion found okay
so
now and so that plan looks good to me
and the both
both tests pass and i assume i ask
a record review from one of my teammates
now i can merge my change to the master
branch
once i merged the change another cloud
build job will kick in
and as you can see this one here and
this is the post
submit deployment job which will
actually do the terrible apply for me
to apply the changes that were just
shown in the speculative plan in the
presumably job
and it's going to print out the traffic
version just for archiving purpose
it's going to do terribly neat it's also
going to show a plan
as well and eventually it's going to
apply the plan to the
to your gcp infrastructure so by the end
of this deployment
i expect to see the audio project being
created
and all the resources being created and
configured in that project
expect to see the monitoring project
being created and also the facet
infrastructure to be stand up
in that project and i also expect to see
the organization policies being
configured
according to the ones that are delivered
by the tariff
engine and this
part will take about um 11 to 12 minutes
because um one of the major piece that
will be created is a cloud sql database
part of the full setting infrastructure
and that takes about
five or six minutes to be created so
um so we are just going to wait for that
to finish
and right now we are still at the
planning phase then after this is
finished
we will move on to the apply phase
and i think if you are watching this
video you can fast forward
to for about 10 minutes and and then
we'll have all the resources provisioned
on gcp
so this deployment has just finished so
this
deployment help us create the audio
project all the resources monitoring
project monitoring resources and
organization policies
so if we go to the the cloud console and
take a look at
the projects it has created for us
so it creates the audio project
the monitor project so if we go to the
audi project
and go to the storage
you can see that the seven-year
long-term storage
locks inc and if we go to the
bigquery you will see that bigquery
locks in as well
and now if we go to the monitor project
and this project is used to host the
entire facility infrastructure
and as you can see it creates the
facility uh
search buckets
it also creates the fossetti
server vm and it's up and running it's a
private instance
and if we go to the cloud sequel
database
you can see it has also created the for
seti server database
so that's for the monitoring and if we
actually
go to a terminal and try to print
the log syncs for this organization
and you can see that there are two log
sync being configured
and each points to the right destination
we just created
so by now uh we've finished the
deployment
of the foundation recipe provided by
terraform engine with the help of ci cd
pipelines so future deployments or
future modifications to infrastructure
if you are for example
adding a new project or if you are um
adding a new storage bucket they should
be um
made they should be sent as a pr to this
repository and the same thing will like
you will go through the code review make
sure the prisma test pass
the respect the speculative plan looks
good and then once you submit the pr
the the change will auto deploy it by
the sea by the cloud build
a deployment job
and uh one thing i want to mention uh in
addition as well is
uh for for seti um because right now
facet also needs to
consume a set of policies in order to
know what type of rules you want to
enforce on your infrastructure
so dpt also provides another tool called
policy generator
and that's a tool that is also
configurable and it's based on templates
and it can provide you a set of best
practices
for study policies that you can upload
and let facility consume
right away
so i think um that's all the
components that are included in the
foundation recipe and that concludes the
demo today and i hope you enjoy the
video
and thank you
you